This video is sponsored by the Great Courses
Plus.
It's no secret that Albert Einstein worked
at the Swiss Patent Office after graduating
from his university studies.
He had really wanted a job in physics, teaching
or researching, but his university professors
wouldn't really cooperate and wouldn't give
him good recommendations.
He'd had reasonably good grades, but had a
few falling outs with professors he didn't
like.
Eventually, it was through his friend's dad,
that Einstein got the job of examining patent
applications.
It was a matter of looking through various
mechanical inventions, and assessing their
practicality and originality to see if the
inventor should be granted rights over the
idea.
It does seem an intriguing thought, to wonder
how his time in this job may have influenced
Einstein's later work.
So out of curiosity, I've tracked down some
of the actual patents that Einstein approved.
Einstein worked at the patent office from
1902 to 1909, which spans the period of time
when Einstein published his groundbreaking
papers and began to gain recognition.
So it doesn't seem unreasonable that this
work provided at least some inspiration.
However, not all of the inventions were glamorous.
Let's take a look at this first one.
It's a weather indicator based on air humidity,
it's written in German but translates to say
that we have the device based on a twisted
string of animal intestine, that's labelled
with the a in the diagram here, that reacts
to the moisture content of the air, and changes
in humidity caused the intestine to twist,
which moves the needle in the display.
Einstein himself looked at this and thought
'seems legit'.
And actually, the concept has been used a
lot.
For example, in hygrometers, or weather houses.
The intestine is called a catgut.
But it is not made from cats.
Rather, it's made from sheep, goat or cattle.
This next pattern was for a gravel sorting
machine, a series of various sized wire mesh
cylinders are rotated using the handle, with
gravel coming in through this side, small
gravel will fall through the fine mesh with
larger gravel making its way to the large
mesh, and that sorts the gravel.
Patents are practical engineering based solutions,
rather than the deeply theoretical and abstract
work that Einstein would later become famous
for.
Here's another one that Einstein approved.
It's for a kind of electrical typewriter.
With this, the keys are still pressed by a
person, but the metal lever which imprints
the paper now moves electrically, rather than
mechanically.
And this is some detail regarding that process.
There's a bit of a conspiracy swirling around
that Einstein stole some of his greatest ideas
from the patents that he read.
There are obvious practical challenges to
pulling that off.
But it also doesn't make a lot of sense, given
that patent applications are not the same
as scientific papers.
They don't present new theoretical ideas,
but rather the commercial applications.
But it does seem likely to me that having
access to cutting edge inventions, and having
to think deeply about the ideas behind them
certainly would have helped, especially when
Einstein was able to read patents surrounding
ideas in electromagnetism, transmission of
signals and even the synchronisation of time.
Here is one that Einstein reviewed that was
submitted by the General Electric Company,
an AC commutators with short circuit brushes
and opposite brush auxiliary coils to avoid
sparks.
It's always good to try and minimise the amount
of cables going to or from a machine.
So here they are using anchor points of the
machine as a way to connect the commutator
coil.
But what's really interesting is that it includes
one of the only surviving notes written by
Einstein while he was working at the office.
It's a sort of rejection letter, saying that
the patent claim is incorrect, imprecise and
not clearly formulated.
Einstein's boss at the patent office had in
fact told Einstein that "when you pick up
an application, you should think that anything
the inventor says is wrong".
It would seem that in his earlier conflict
with authority whilst a student Einstein already
had a bit of this mindset, but this attitude
to work must have helped him to forge new
ground by not being limited to existing beliefs.
Einstein then got promoted to technical expert
at a time when the office was seing a growing
number of patents regarding electric timekeeping
and synchronisation of clocks.
This application likely came across his desk
for an electromagnetically controlled pendulum
that would take a signal and correct a distant
pendulum clock.
Many people were thinking about clocks, not
as thought experiments, but because keeping
clocks synchronised was a real problem.
Patents were being filed trying to help determine
train arrival times using coordinated clocks.
But it was Einstein who made a jump to realising
there was an inseparable relation between
time and space.
In 1905, he published his work on special
relativity, as well as the photoelectric effect,
Brownian motion and the energy mass equivalence.
Long after he left the patent office, he was
still developing ideas based on current gaps
in physics, and gaining plenty of his own
Patents, including his ideas for an adjustable
blouse.
But not all of Einstein's ideas were great
or even correct.
And I think it's important to remember that
even people who have been elevated to genius
status, have made mistakes or have failed.
If you would like to hear more about Einstein's
flaws, then I know just the thing for you.
This course called What Einstein Got Wrong,
is on the Great Courses Plus, who have sponsored
today's video.
The Great Courses Plus is an on-demand video
learning service, with lectures and courses
from top professors, and also content from
places like National Geographic and the Smithsonian.
They have a huge library of over 11,000 video
lectures about anything that interests you.
What Einstein Got Wrong is taught by Dan Hooper,
the head of the theoretical physics group
at Fermilab.
And I found it to be a nice way to remind
myself of Einstein's achievements, but to
also learn a few new things about some of
his flawed reasoning.
If you would like to explore any of the courses
for yourself, you can head to TheGreatCoursesPlus.com/Tibees
to access a free trial.
That link can be found down in the description.
Thanks to The Great Courses Plus, and also
to my Patreon supporters for enabling me to
make videos.
A special shout out to today's Patron cat
of the day Moriko.